being the acting returning officer for
the Nottingham south constituency at the
UK parliamentary election held on
thursday the seventh of may 2015 to
hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate are as
follows Clayworth andrew william trade
unist and socialist coalition 230
Greenwood Lillian Rachel Labour Party
20,000 697
hollis davidian UK Independence Party
4,900 hunt hunt Jane Marion the
Conservative Party candidate 13,000 761
macgregor Adam Fergus the Green Party
2345 Newton cook Deborah violet Liberal
Democrats 1532 and I do hereby declare
that the said Lilian Greenwood is duly
elected there were 234 rejected votes
thank
where to start well first of all I
suppose I should say don't believe
everything that you read on the BBC and
the Nottingham post website and it's
been a long campaign it's been a long
day and it's been a long night so I'll
keep it brief first of all can I say
some thank yous to my amazing family to
Ravi and my three daughters Patsy
Matilda and Elsie we're all here tonight
you put up with so much having a wife
and a mom as an MP and you've just been
tremendous so thank you um last time in
2010 I forgot to thank I can't believe
with it I forgot to thank my wonderful
Agent Brian barber is just an absolutely
amazing amazing counselor and he's the
best agent that anyone could one and I'm
also going to thank Georgia Power who's
the Nottingham labor agent who's just
been an absolute power and really in a
way being an MP is a bit of a team
effort I couldn't do it without my
amazing staff Carol david d Lawrence and
rich you've just been fantastic all the
time you've worked for me and with me
and when you take time off to camp in as
well and of course we are a team and
Nottingham labor team and I'm proud to
work with all our Nottingham Labour
councillors candidates and our fantastic
campaign volunteers and while I'm doing
thank yous thank you too with the
returning officer to the polling staff
to the county and staff to the police
and everybody who works here at the
Tennis Center but most of all of course
I want to thank my constituents across
notting himself it's been a huge
privilege and a great pleasure to
represent you for the last five years
and I'm just incredibly proud that you
voted for me to continue to represent
you in the future i'll always listen to
your concerns
always stand up for you in Parliament
and I'll always speak up for our great
city of Nottingham now I know that many
of you have been hit hard by the
tory-led government families face a
cost-of-living crisis students face a
mountain of debt and some of our most
vulnerable citizens are forced to turn
to food banks tonight I fear for my
constituents and what five more years of
this government will mean but I will do
everything in my power to fight for you
and your families because you we and our
city and our country deserve better
thank
you